So it turns out that
bubbles pop real fast.
Whoa.
Ooh.
Really good one.
Yeah. Stop it.
Ow!
It also really hurts if
you chuck in someone's eye.
So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna shoot it.
We're gonna shoot it.
What?
We're gonna shoot it, 18.
.
18,000.
18,000 frames per second.
It's definitely going to surface,
it's just gonna like.
I'm gonna wash my eye
and I'll be right back.
Hah!
I'm gonna shoot this on a macro lens.
It's gonna be really close up
and it's gonna be at
18,000 frames a second
using the VE1610.
Hopefully it will look top.
What should we do now, then?
Okay, well, I've got a 7.62 bullet,
and I'm gonna drop it through the bubble
and see if it makes it to
the bottom of the bubble
before the bubble has
completely collapsed.
See which one happens first?
Gravity or bubble?
Let's go.
Let's do it.
Yeah.